Yeah, and that was Steve's MO. Steve would tend to arrive to meetings a little early. His question was, you know, why are you here? Why are you here now? So, and if you didn't give an acceptable answer, he was like, recorded on May 19th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we wrap up our three-part interview with Sean Parent, where he tells us some of his awesome Steve Jobs stories. Fast forward until after I left Apple. So, you know, I left Apple after five years and went to Adobe to work on Photoshop. And so I joined Adobe end of 93
是的，史蒂夫的行事风格就是这样。史蒂夫通常会稍微提前一点到达会议现场。他会问，你知道的，你为什么在这里？你为什么现在在这里？所以，如果你没有给出让人满意的回答，他的态度就会像是在2021年5月19日录制的那样。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持布莱斯一起，结束了我们对肖恩·帕伦特的三个部分访谈，他在访谈中向我们讲述了一些他经历的关于史蒂夫·乔布斯的精彩故事。时间快进到我离开苹果之后。所以，你知道的，我在苹果待了五年后离开，去了Adobe参与Photoshop的开发。因此我在93年底加入了Adobe
to work on Photoshop. And a couple of years after that, Steve Jobs came back to Apple. So I always say I worked at Apple between jobs because I joined Apple right after Steve left and I left Apple right before Steve came back. So I worked at Apple between jobs. So Steve came back and Apple proposed this operating system called Rhapsody, which was basically Next Step. And they said they were canceling traditional macOS and they were going to move to Rhapsody, which was Next Step, which had came out of Next Computing, which is a company that Stephen formed. And at the time, Apple had about 2% market share and was falling. And so the idea of supporting a new and different, radically different platform on what amounted
参与Photoshop的开发。几年后，史蒂夫·乔布斯回到了苹果。所以我总是说我在两份工作之间曾在苹果工作，因为我加入苹果正是在史蒂夫离开之后，而我离开苹果又是在史蒂夫回来之前。所以我其实是在两次工作交替的间隙在苹果呆过。后来史蒂夫回来了，苹果推出了一个名为Rhapsody的操作系统，这基本上就是Next Step。他们说他们要取消传统的macOS，转向Rhapsody，也就是Next Step，它源于NeXT Computing，那是史蒂夫创立的一家公司。当时，苹果的市场份额只有大约2%还在不断下滑。因此，在一个堪称
to a failing company was not particularly of interest to Adobe. And so both Adobe and Microsoft had basically said, well, you know, that's very nice, but we decline. We won't be supporting your new operating system. And before I had left Apple, I had worked at Apple on the transition from 68K processors to PowerPC processors. So, you know, I kind of knew, you know, at the very low level, kind of how the operating system worked and how it was brought up and, you know, enough that I could bring up, you know, with high amount of compatibility, you know, a 68k box running in a PowerPC box. And so I wrote this
濒死边缘的公司里，去支持一个全新的、与以往截然不同的平台，这并不能引起Adobe的特别兴趣。所以当时Adobe和微软基本上都说，嗯，你知道的，这很好，但我们拒绝。我们不会支持你们的新操作系统。在我离开苹果之前，我曾在苹果参与过从68K处理器向PowerPC处理器过渡的工作。所以，你知道的，我在非常底层上多少了解操作系统是如何工作的，它是如何被引导启动的，（了解得）足够多到我可以让一个
about a page and a half proposal that was known as the Cyan proposal. It was Cyan because Apple always color-coded their OSs, and Cyan was an unused color, and Cyan is kind of a blend between blue and green, tending towards yellow a little bit. And Rhapsody, I think, was going to be yellow. And traditional Mac OS was blue. And so I wrote this Cyan proposal. And basically, it was a proposal for how you could have Mac compatibility
运行在PowerPC盒子里的68K盒子以极高的兼容性启动起来。于是我写了大约一页半的提案，被称为Cyan提案。之所以叫Cyan（青色），是因为苹果总是用颜色来给他们的操作系统编码，而Cyan是一个闲置的颜色，它有点介于蓝色和绿色之间，稍微偏向一点黄色。而Rhapsody，我记得原本应该是黄色。传统的Mac OS则是蓝色。于是我写了这个Cyan提案。基本上，这是一个关于如何在
inside of this Rhapsody environment. And this was while you were at Apple or while you were at Adobe? Well, it was at Adobe. I wrote this proposal up. And floated it up the management chain, and it went to John Warnock, who at the time was our CEO. And we had lots of conversations, and John was like, yeah, okay, if Apple did this, then we would support their new operating system. And so then we ended up in discussions with Apple about, okay, you want us to support your new operating system?
Rhapsody环境中实现Mac兼容性的提案。这是你在苹果的时候还是在Adobe的时候？嗯，是在Adobe的时候。我写好了这个提案，并把它向上提交到了管理层，最终送到了当时的CEO约翰·沃纳克手里。我们进行了很多次对话，约翰的态度是，好吧，如果苹果这样做，那么我们就会支持他们的新操作系统。于是我们最终与苹果展开了讨论，内容是：好吧，你们想让我们支持你们的新操作系统？
Then build this bridge, and we'll support your new operating system. And Craig Gilley was my boss at the time, and he kind of took point on most of these negotiations and so at one of the meetings with Apple this was fairly senior like director of engineering at Apple at the time Greg had you know, if you don't do this, why would we support your operating system? And the director of engineering from Apple said, well, you know, if you don't do this, I'm just gonna build my own Photoshop and put you guys out of business, was his basic response. To which Greg responded, if you really think that you could do that, I suggest you do,
那就把这座桥建好，我们就支持你们的新操作系统。克雷格·吉利当时是我的老板，他基本上牵头负责了大部分谈判。所以在与苹果的一次会议上，当时苹果的一位级别相当高的人，比如工程总监，格雷格当时说：如果你不这么做，我们为什么要支持你们的新操作系统？苹果的工程总监说，好吧，你知道的，如果你不这么做，我就会自己做一个Photoshop，让你们破产，这是他的基本回应。格雷格对此回应道，如果你真的认为你能做到这一点，我建议你去做，
because you'll make way more money than what you're doing right now. And that turned into kind of a heated argument between the two of them. At the time, I actually thought it was going to come to to physical blows like they were like chest to chest um um is this at adobe or like is this meeting taking place at adobe was taking place at adobe and so they were literally like chest to chest you know pointing so after this meeting the person from Apple wrote an email that went to Warnock that was that he could no longer negotiate
因为你赚的钱会比你现在做的事多得多。这演变成了一场激烈的争吵。当时，我甚至以为他们俩要动起手来了，他们就像是胸口贴着胸口……嗯……这是在Adobe吗？还是说这个会议是在Adobe开的？是在Adobe开的。所以他们真的是胸口贴着胸口，互相指指点点。开完会后，苹果的那位代表给沃纳克写了一封邮件，说他再也不能跟Adobe谈判了，
with Adobe because Greg was a hothead. So if Adobe wanted to continue negotiations, it would have to be with somebody else. So I got tagged and was like, okay, so Sean, you get to continue the negotiations around this. And so we set up another meeting.
因为格雷格是个冲动狂。所以如果Adobe想继续谈判，就必须换个人。于是我被点名了，心想：好吧，肖恩，接下来由你来继续推进这部分的谈判。于是我们安排了另一场会议。
This one was at Apple. And the meeting was supposed to basically go in two parts where Adobe presented the business reality of why we wouldn't support Rhapsody as it was, you know, the cost to us of moving our products to a new platform, the opportunity costs involved, the technical challenges and basically lay out the case for why we weren't going to do it. And you know, in less, Apple kind of met us halfway. And on the flip side, Apple was going to present their analysis of the Cyan proposal. It was myself and Ross Bott.
这场会议是在苹果公司举行的。会议原本计划大致分为两部分：首先由Adobe阐述为什么我们不会支持现状下的Rhapsody的商业现实，也就是我们将产品迁移到新平台所需的成本、其中涉及的机会成本、技术挑战，并从根本上陈述我们不打算这么做的理由。除非苹果能在某种程度上满足我们的要求。而在另一方面，苹果将展示他们对Cyan提案的分析。出席的有我和罗斯·博特。
Ross Bott was an executive at Adobe, and he was handling kind of the number side, the marketing side of it, and I was handling the technical side of it. And so we go to this meeting, and we do our presentation on the technical aspects and the numbers aspects. And then it's like, okay, Apple, it's your turn to give your presentation. And this same individual who had been in an argument with Greg says,
罗斯·博特是Adobe的高管，他主要负责数字和市场营销这一块，而我负责技术方面。于是我们去参加了这个会议，就技术层面和数据层面做了我们的展示。然后就变成了：好的，苹果，轮到你们做展示了。而那个曾与格雷格争吵过的人却说：
well, we looked at this proposal that Sean wrote and it can't be built. And like, that was it. they had like no slides no presentation no numbers no anything and I got mad and I'm like I'm like that's bs uh he was like nope I've had like all the you know best senior engineers we have here look at this they say nope it can't be built i'm like like you're full of blank you know if you just if you want to hire me back let me put my own team together i'll build it and uh so it went it went really well then the the meeting. So, yeah, so the meeting went really, really well. So I get back to the office, and I don't even think the day was over.
嗯，我们看了肖恩写的这个提案，这根本造不出来。就这样，没了。他们没有幻灯片、没有展示、没有数据、什么都没有。我当时就火了，心想：这简直是胡扯。他却说：不，我让我们这里所有最优秀的资深工程师都看过了，他们都说不行，根本造不出来。我说：你纯粹是在放……你知道的。如果你想重新雇佣我，让我自己组建一个团队，我来把它造出来。所以，嗯……这次会议进展得非常顺利。所以，是的，这次会议实际上非常非常顺利。我回到办公室时，甚至觉得一天都还没结束。
I get an email from John Warnock, and it's a forward of an email from this director of engineering Apple that says you know that the whole problem with dealing with Adobe was you know was was me as a as an ex Apple employee with an X to grind, and that I didn't know what I was talking about, and I was impossible to work with. And so this is just a forwarded email just slamming me personally with a note from John at the top that says, I want to see you in my office now. That was the extent of the note.
我收到了约翰·沃纳克发来的一封邮件，里面转发了苹果那位工程总监的邮件。邮件里说，跟Adobe打交道的所有问题都在于我——一个带着个人怨恨的前苹果员工，而且我根本不知道自己在说些什么，根本无法共事。这只是一封对我进行人身攻击的转发邮件，而约翰在邮件顶部留下一句话：我希望你现在就来我办公室。邮件就这么简短。
So, you know, I went through my office thinking, okay, well, if I'm getting escorted out of the building, what do I want to take home today? And I called John's assistant and said, you know, John sent me this note. He wants to speak with me now. And she said, yeah, he's waiting for you. Come on up.
所以，你知道的，我穿过办公室心想：好吧，如果我要被保安护送离开大楼，今天我有什么想带回家的？我给约翰的助理打了电话，说：约翰给我发了这条信息，他现在就要跟我谈谈。她说：是的，他在等你，上来吧。
So, you know, go up to the 18th floor of the tower. It's's what you would expect you know a ceo's office to be like right and um i i get there and uh john's like oh sean come on in come on in like have a seat i'm like oh i'm like shaking and sweating, right? I think this is the end of my career. And he goes, just sit there. Just listen. I just wanted you to be here for this. And he picks up the phone to his assistant, and he tells her, can you get Steve on the line? And she says, yes. So there's a pause, and the phone rings again, and he tells her can you get steve on the line and she says yes so there's a pause and phone rings again and he picks it up he's like steve i'm putting you on speakerphone
于是，你知道的，我上了大楼的18楼。那就是你所期望的CEO办公室应有的样子，对吧？我到了那里，约翰就说：哦，肖恩，进来，进来，坐吧。我心想：哦，我在发抖，在冒汗，对吧？我觉得这是我职业生涯的尽头了。而他说：就坐在那儿听着。我只是想让你在这里亲历这件事。他拿起电话打给助理，对她说：你能把史蒂夫接进来吗？她说：可以。于是有一段暂停，电话又响了，他对她说：你能把史蒂夫接进来吗？她说：可以。于是有一段暂停，电话又响了，他接起电话说：史蒂夫，我把你开免提了。
puts it on speakerphone and it's steve jobs from apple and uh he goes he goes hey steve it's john they go through a couple pleasantries he goes yep I'm calling you today about this Rhapsody thing I just want to tell you we're not doing it and we're not discussing it anymore and he hangs up the phone and he turns to me and he says he says you know he said for them
他按了免提，电话那头是来自苹果的史蒂夫·乔布斯。他说：嘿，史蒂夫，我是约翰。他们客套了几句，他说：没错，我今天打电话给你是为了这个Rhapsody的事情，我只是想告诉你，我们不干了，我们也不再讨论这事了。然后他挂了电话，转过身对我说：
to come back and say that they can't work with you when we had already told them no and you're the only person who me and he says he says you know he said for them to come back and say that they can't work with you when we had already told them no and you're the only person who was trying to salvage the situation he said is is just ridiculous he said so so we're done and and you know i would leave the story there but for your listeners the time passes probably about a year and a half from from this point in time and i'm sitting in my office you know at adobe working away on on photoshop and my phone rings and i pick it up i said hello and they're like hello is this sean parent i'm like yeah this is sean parent and it's like this is steve jobs i'm like
他说：你知道的，他说他们竟然还回头说无法与你合作，而我们之前就已经拒绝过他们了，你本来是唯一一个试图挽救局面的人。他说这简直太荒谬了。所以他说：我们不干了。你知道的，我本来可以把故事留在这里，但为了听众着想，时间大概从这个时间节点又过去了大约一年半，我正坐在Adobe的办公室里埋头开发Photoshop，这时我的电话响了。我接起来说：喂。对方说：喂，请问是肖恩·帕伦特吗？我说：对，我是肖恩·帕伦特。对方说：我是史蒂夫·乔布斯。我说：
yeah they're like they're like no this is steve. I'm like, yeah. They're like, no, this is Steve Jobs. I'm like, okay, well, hi, Steve. What can I do for you? And he said, I'm calling to personally invite you over to Apple. I've got a presentation I want to give to some of the Adobe folks. So I'm calling each of you individually and inviting you personally to come over. So it gives me the time,
是的。对方说：不，我是史蒂夫。我说：对。对方说：不，我是史蒂夫·乔布斯。我说：好吧，嗨，史蒂夫。有什么我可以帮你的吗？他说：我打电话是想亲自邀请你来苹果一趟。我有一个演示要在一些Adobe的员工面前做。所以我正在挨个给你们打电话，亲自邀请你们过来。于是他给了我时间，
and it was myself and Greg and Mark Hamburg, who was a technical lead on Photoshop at the time, a couple of other people from some of the non-Photoshop product teams also. And we go over to this meeting at Apple, and Steve comes into the room, and he said, this is what I'm going to present at WWDC, which is Apple's Worldwide Developer Conference, in about two weeks and he goes through a set of slides for Mac OS X. And he said so we're going to be announcing Mac OS X at WWDC and here's the slide
去的人有我和格雷格，还有马克·汉堡（当时Photoshop的技术主管），以及来自非Photoshop产品团队的一些其他人。我们去苹果参加了这个会议，史蒂夫走进房间说：这就是我大约两周后要在WWDC（苹果全球开发者大会）上演示的内容。接着他展示了一套关于Mac OS X的幻灯片。他说：我们将在WWDC上宣布Mac OS X，这就是幻灯片
deck and he goes I want Adobe's commitment here and now that you guys will support OS X and I said nothing like okay and so we said you know we had a conversation and we had enough people in the room we said we can commit to this and he said okay I want to show Photoshop running on OS X in two weeks and so we said we'll do our best and yeah a bunch of us got very little sleep for two weeks and and you can look it up online. You can probably hunt it down and find a link in the show notes. But Greg Gilley presented Photoshop running on OSX at WWDC two weeks later. And it's a horrible presentation because Greg was completely
文稿。他说：我需要Adobe在此立下承诺，你们会支持OS X。我当时心想：好吧。于是我们说：你知道的，我们进行了一番交流，房间里有足够多的人，我们说我们可以做出这个承诺。他说：好，我要在两周后看到Photoshop在OS X上运行。于是我们说：我们会尽最大努力。是的，我们一帮人为了这两周几乎没怎么睡觉。你们可以在网上查到这个。你们或许能把它找出来，并在节目文稿里找到一个链接。但两周后，格雷格·吉利确实在WWDC上演示了Photoshop在OS X上的运行。那是一场糟糕的演示，因为格雷格当时完全
sleep deprived. And he starts rambling about how he was, you know, writing code during the family barbecue the night before the WWDC. And so it kind of goes into this long ramble about his family barbecue. So, you know, Photoshop is all crazy, and I'm dealing with all the fires that are coming up and dealing with that. And then my brother comes in town, and so I've got him and his family, and so we, you know, are trying to run around with them. And so I've got him and his family. And so we are trying to run around with them. And so actually, on this past Friday, I actually went down to Monterey Bay Aquarium
睡眠严重不足。他开始语无伦次地唠叨，说自己在WWDC前一晚的家庭烧烤聚会期间还在写代码。所以他差不多是陷入了一段关于他家庭烧烤的长篇大论。所以，你知道的，Photoshop到处出状况，我得处理各种突发状况。接着我弟弟来到了镇上，所以家里有他和他的家人，我们得带着他们到处转。所以家里有他和他的家人，我们要带着他们到处转。实际上就在上周五，我去了蒙特雷湾水族馆，
and left the machine with a couple of engineers on the Photoshop team who finally got to the point where the disks were going to manufacturing. So they had a few minutes of time. And they fixed a couple of things which had been nagging me. And then so Saturday, we had a barbecue minutes of time and they fixed a couple of things which had been nagging me and then so saturday we had a barbecue in my backyard and i was i was in there i was fixing trying to get the last couple of things fixing trying to get them worked and i burned the steaks
把机器留给了Photoshop团队的几位工程师，他们终于把光盘送去压盘制造了。所以他们有了一点空闲时间。他们修复了几个一直困扰我的问题。然后到了周六，我们在后院举行了一场烧烤。有一点时间，他们修复了几个一直困扰我的问题，接着星期六我们在我后院弄了次烧烤，我当时正忙着呢，试图把最后几个问题修复好，结果把牛排烤糊了。
um so my wife gave me grief for that but um and let's see and then of course sunday was mother's day and didn't didn't didn't you say that when steve present like unveiled this at wd wwdc didn't he say something like they said which you found amusing because a year earlier yes it was yes he did use exactly those words they you know whoever they were and and it was. Yes, he did use exactly those words. They, you know, whoever they were. And it was it was somewhat annoying. Yeah, there was there's there's so many interesting side stories in this in this time frame, because the Cyan proposal went a little further after Apple turned it down, which was one of the people who I'd worked with at Apple.
所以……我妻子为此没少数落我。不过，然后呢，当然周日就是母亲节了。你不是说过当史蒂夫在WWDC上展示、发布这个时，他说过类似于“他们说……”的话吗？你不觉得这挺有意思的吗，因为就在一年以前……是的，没错，他确实用了那些原话。他们，不管他们是谁，而且这……是的，他确实用了那些原话。他们，不管他们是谁。而且这……这多少有点让人恼火。是的，这段时间里有太多有趣的插曲了，因为Cyan提案在苹果拒绝之后其实还走得更远了一点。其中一个曾在苹果和我共事过的人，
He had actually started as mine and Scott Boyd's intern at Apple, Eric Trout. He wrote the dynamic recompiling emulator for 68K to PowerPC that Apple was using. And I knew Greg Gallinos, who had created a company called MetroWorks, and they kind of had Apple's development tools, but development tools for the Apple platform, CodeWarrior tools, which were very popular at the time. But something else that MetroWorks had was a library that emulated some of the Macintosh on PCs.
他最初其实是我和斯科特·博伊德在苹果的实习生，叫埃里克·特劳特。他写了苹果正在使用的、用于将68K动态重新编译为PowerPC的模拟器。我认识格雷格·加利诺斯，他创立了一家名为MetroWorks的公司，他们当时掌握着苹果的开发工具，确切地说是针对苹果平台的开发工具——CodeWarrior工具，这在当时非常受欢迎。但MetroWorks还有一样东西，那就是一个能在PC上模拟部分麦金塔电脑的库。
Now I'm drawing a blank as to what the name of the library was, so long as you kind of recompiled. And Eric then had worked at Connectix, and they did something called Speed Doubler, which was a way to speed up the emulated portions of PowerPC systems at the time. At this company, Connectix. He later went on to Microsoft and worked on the Hypervisor, and he's now retired. Eric and I kind of got together and kicked this around and said, you know, we know enough people that we could build a Mac-compatible
现在我想不起来那个库叫什么名字了，只要你重新编译一下就行。埃里克后来去了Connectix，他们做了一款名为Speed Doubler的产品，那是当时加速PowerPC系统模拟部分的一种方法。在Connectix这家公司工作之后，他后来去了微软从事Hypervisor的工作，现在已经退休了。埃里克和我聚在一起琢磨这件事，心想：我们认识足够多的人，完全可以打造一个兼容Mac的
system. If Apple's going to kill the Mac, we could put together a consortium of companies basically to build Mac compatibles. And, you know, Macs at the time had opened themselves up for cloning. So there were these hardware manufacturers that had geared up to build Mac clones. And then when Steve Jobs came back in, he kind of shut down all the clones. And so companies like IBM had been geared up to build PowerPC Max and then had to shut it all down. And we knew folks at Bee, which was a company that built an operating system that ran on PowerPCs. And so we kind of hatched this idea of, well, we could take Bee OS and we could take the MetroWorks library and we could take the technology that Eric had been working on and we could put together all of
系统。如果苹果要杀死Mac，我们可以把一帮公司联合成一个财团来制造Mac兼容机。而且，你知道的，当时的Mac已经向克隆开放了。所以当时有很多硬件制造商已经摩拳擦掌准备制造Mac克隆机。后来当史蒂夫·乔布斯回归后，他实际上关闭了所有的克隆授权。因此像IBM这样的公司原本已经准备好制造PowerPC Mac，结果却不得不全部叫停。我们认识B公司的人，那是一家开发在PowerPC上运行的操作系统的公司。于是我们萌生了一个想法：我们可以采用B OS，采用MetroWorks的库，采用埃里克一直在研究的技术，把所有这些
these pieces and we could build Mac compatible power PCs. And we know all the hardware manufacturers who were going to build Mac clones and perhaps they would be interested in building Mac clones without Apple. And we scheduled a meeting. It was going to be just a handful of basically engineer types to talk about the technical feasibility over at B headquarters. This had kind of leaked beyond the engineers who were talking about it to executives. And so I walked into this room, and know, Jean-Louis Gosset,
部分拼凑起来，我们就能制造出Mac兼容的PowerPC。而且我们认识所有那些原本准备制造Mac克隆机的硬件制造商，也许他们会对在没有苹果参与的情况下制造Mac克隆机感兴趣。我们安排了一场会议。原本只打算让一小撮工程师类型的人在B公司的总部碰面，讨论一下技术可行性。但这消息不知怎么的，从讨论它的工程师层面泄露到了高管那里。于是我走进了那个会议室，看到了让·勒鲁瓦·加塞（曾任职于苹果后来创立了B公司的这个人）以及来自IBM和其他公司的资深高管。
who had been at Apple and had then started the B Corporation and senior executives from IBM and these other companies. And we sat for an hour and discussed the technical feasibility. And what it basically came down to is, could we get the software manufacturers, the big software manufacturers, to commit to support this platform, right? If we were going to build a consortium of companies, could we get the software to back it up?
我们坐了一个小时，讨论了技术可行性。而归根结底的问题是：我们能让软件制造商、大型软件制造商承诺支持这个平台吗？如果我们打算建立一个公司财团，我们能获得软件方面的支持吗？
And that led me back to John Warnock's office to say, hey, would you support this Mac clone? And John came back and said, no, I wouldn't. He said, for two reasons. One is, it's a high-risk thing. He said, I think, he said, in his opinion, he said he thinks that the hardware manufacturers are actually playing you. He said they have a bunch of sunk costs into building Mac clones that they're looking to recoup. And they want to do one generation and burn off their hardware.
这让我重新回到了约翰·沃纳克的办公室，去问：嘿，你会支持这个Mac克隆版吗？约翰回答说：不，我不会。他说，原因有二。第一，这是一件高风险的事情。他说，他认为，在他看来，硬件制造商实际上在耍你们。他说他们在制造Mac克隆机上投入了大量沉没成本，现在正指望捞回本呢。他们只想做一代产品，把他们的硬件库存消耗完。
And then they'll be done with this. So he said from a business standpoint, he said, I think, you know, you're getting used. So tread carefully. And he said the other thing that he had learned, he said, I think, you know, you're getting used. So tread carefully. And he said, the other thing that he had learned, he said, was to never take Steve on head to head. He said, it's one thing to tell Steve, you know, I'm doing this or I'm not doing this. It's another thing to actually go and try to compete with the man. And he said, he's, you know, he has a long relationship with Steve, which, you know, the whole laser writer thing and Adobe got started largely out of Steve's support from Apple. And so he said, I'm not going to go compete against Steve head to head.
然后他们就会退出这档子事。所以他说从商业角度来看，他说，我认为，你知道的，你们在被人利用。所以要小心行事。他还说，他学到的另一件事是：永远不要跟史蒂夫正面硬刚。他说，告诉史蒂夫“我要这么做”或者“我绝不这么做”是一回事，而真正去跟这个人竞争则是另一回事。他说，他跟史蒂夫有着长期的交往（你知道的，整个激光打印机的故事以及Adobe的崛起很大程度上都源于史蒂夫对苹果的支持）。所以他说：我才不会去跟史蒂夫正面竞争呢。
And so I'm out. And kind of without Adobe's commitment, we couldn't get Microsoft's commitment. And the whole strategy just kind of without Adobe's commitment, we couldn't get Microsoft's commitment and the whole strategy just kind of unraveled. But, you know. Where were you working at the time? I was at Adobe. You were still on Adobe Gatch, yeah. Yeah, so I was at Adobe from 93 until 2009.
所以我退出。如果没有Adobe的承诺，我们就无法获得微软的承诺，整个战略也就这样土崩瓦解了。不过，你知道的……你当时在哪里工作？我在Adobe。你当时还在Adobe，对吧？是的，所以我从93年一直待到2009年在Adobe。
And then I went to Google for a little over a year and then back to Adobe and I've been at Adobe since it must have been pretty like there's not a lot of people that can uh stand up to Steve Jobs and it sounds like John Warnack was one of them yeah yeah you know there there are you know a few other stories you know I was in a few meetings during that time period with Steve. And John was one of the few people who would stand up to Steve. And there seemed to be a huge amount of respect there. You know, John, I actually saw John tell Steve, Steve, have a seat. And Steve kind of, you know, shut up and sat down.
然后我去了谷歌一年多，接着又回到了Adobe，并且一直呆在Adobe到现在。能跟史蒂夫·乔布斯叫板的人可不多，听起来约翰·沃纳克就是其中之一。是的，是的，你知道的，还有其他一些故事。在那段时期，我和史蒂夫开过几次会。约翰是极少数敢跟史蒂夫叫板的人之一。而且他们之间似乎有着极大的互相尊重。你知道的，我甚至亲眼看到约翰对史蒂夫说：史蒂夫，坐下。然后史蒂夫就（你知道的）闭嘴坐下了。
If I recall correctly, the background of that story was, wasn't it that Steve had come into the meeting and started asking each person in the meeting who they were and why they were there, and then telling them whether or not to remain in the meeting? Yeah. Yeah. And that was Steve's MO. Steve would tend to arrive to meetings a little early. And even, you know, this was a meeting at Adobe, so this was not a meeting that he had. And he would walk into the meeting and people who were already there and then people who came into the room, his question was, you know, why are you here? And person might give, you know, well, I'm the so-and-so. People answer that question with their title, right?
如果我没记错的话，那个故事的背景是，史蒂夫走进会议室，开始询问会议中的每个人他们是谁、为什么来这里，然后决定是否让他们留在会场里？是的。是的，这正是史蒂夫的行事风格。史蒂夫通常会稍微提前一点到达会议室。甚至，你知道的，这是一场在Adobe开的会，所以这不是他自己的主场。他会走进会议室，对于已经在里面的人以及随后走进房间的人，他的问题都是：你知道的，你为什么在这里？而对方可能会回答说，嗯，我是某某某。人们回答这个问题时通常会报出自己的职位，对吧？
I'm the lead on blank product. He'd be like, that wasn't the question. Why are you here now? And if you didn't give an acceptable answer, he was like, you don't need to be here. Get out. Such a nice guy. Yeah. Yeah.
我是某某产品的负责人。而他会说：这不是问题所在。你为什么现在在这里？如果你没有给出令人满意的回答，他就会说：你不需要呆在这里，滚出去。真是个好人啊。是的，是的。
You know, kind of everything you see in the movies about him is, you know, has some amount of accuracy. You know, he's an incredibly smart guy, had an incredible aura around him, if you will, the kind of reality distortion field that he's famous for, could convince you of almost anything. And in many ways that served him very well, right? He was a very good motivator, and would push people outside of their limits. And a lot of times, you know, it was just by telling people, you know, no, that's not, that's not right. I don't know what's right. That's not it. Do better. Right? And just
你知道的，你在电影里看到的关于他的每一件事，都有一定程度的真实性。他是一个极其聪明的人，身上有一种不可思议的气场，也就是他著名的“现实扭曲场”，几乎能说服你相信任何事情。在很多方面，这对他非常有利，对吧？他是一个非常好的激励者，会把人们逼到极限之外。很多时候，你知道的，他只是通过对人们说：不，这不对。我不知道什么才是对的，但绝不是这样。做得更好。对吧？就这样
pushing people to go back and do better and try again and to try to impress the man. And so I wouldn't say he was an individual who I'd ever want as a friend, but as somebody running the company, he was very effective. Yeah, certainly. Yeah. There's nothing I love more than Sean war stories from that particular period of time. I think the first time, it was the first time we met Sean. And so for those that aren't familiar with Silicon Valley, Adobe's headquarters are in San Jose, which is sort of at the bottom of Silicon Valley. And I think Apple's offices, either the new one or the old one have always been in Cupertino. So is that where those meetings were taking place going back and forth between Cupertino and San Jose? Yeah, yeah, it would have been that time it was, you know,
逼着人们回去做得更好、再试一次，试图去给这个人留下深刻印象。所以我不会说他是我永远想与之成为朋友的人，但作为公司的掌舵人，他非常高效。确实如此。是的。我最喜欢的就是听肖恩讲述那个特定时期的“战争故事”。我想第一次，那是我和肖恩的初次相遇。对于那些不熟悉硅谷的人来说，Adobe的总部在圣何塞，大致位于硅谷的南部。我想苹果的办公室（无论新旧）一直都在库比蒂诺。所以这些会议都是在库比蒂诺和圣何塞之间来回奔波吗？是的，是的，那时的地点是，
the infinite loop building, right, which was in Cupertino um but yeah the first time i met uh sean we had lunch in the cafeteria of the adobe headquarters and i was i think i we had lunch for like i don't know two hours or two and a half hours it was very kind of you to spend that much time with me and i heard all these stories and when you were telling me the one uh where you go up to john warnock's the ceo's office like i thought for sure you were going to get fired because the way it goes is like you're sent in there as like the second negotiator and been told, all right, so, you know, it didn't go well the first time. You know, let's try and be friends. We want to be we want to have Apple. And then you come out of it just as much of, you know, having gotten an argument.
无限循环大楼，对吧，在库比蒂诺。不过，是的，我第一次见到肖恩时，我们在Adobe总部的食堂吃午饭，我想我们大概吃了一个小时或两个半小时的午饭。你真太好了，花那么多时间陪我，我听到了所有这些故事。当你跟我讲那个你走进CEO约翰·沃纳克办公室的故事时，我以为你死定了，因为剧情的发展是：你作为第二谈判代表被派过去，被告知：“好吧，你知道的，第一次没谈好，我们试着友好一点，我们想跟苹果合作。”然后你从里面出来时，吵得一样不可开交。
And then the punchline of that, of the CEO getting Steve Jobs on the phone and saying, no, thanks. Because it's a good, you sort of, in the midst of hearing the story, you forget that you essentially had written a proposal, like, for Apple. It wasn't really for Adobe. It was, your proposal was like, hey, Apple wasn't really for Adobe. It was you, your proposal was like, Hey, Apple's asking us for this. And we're saying no. Um, and you went out of your way to write a proposal for Apple that said, Hey, if you do this, we can work together. It wasn't for Adobe, uh, per se, it was for the partnership between the companies. And you, you lose sight of that because the story is so amazing and then at the end of it you sort of realize oh yeah sean was the only one that was like nobody else like
而这个故事的高潮是，CEO把史蒂夫·乔布斯叫到电话前，然后说：不，谢谢。因为这是一个好故事，你在听故事的过程中，会忘记你实际上为苹果写了一份提案。它其实不是为Adobe写的，你的提案是……其实不是为Adobe写的，你的提案是：嘿，苹果在向我们索要这个，而我们在拒绝。而且你特意为苹果写了一份提案，上面写着：嘿，如果你们这样做，我们就能合作。它本身不是为了Adobe，它是为了两家公司之间的合作伙伴关系。你会忽略这一点，因为故事太精彩了。到了最后你才会恍然大悟：哦，对啊，肖恩是唯一一个……就像没人像……
you know for for all we know uh you know your your direct reports or people you were reporting to were saying okay you can spend a little bit of time but like we got other stuff to do so um you know don't waste two weeks writing up this proposal or whatever. Yeah, it's crazy. It's an amazing story. And I've heard, you know, I've heard conflicting stories from inside of Apple. You know, what was referred to as Blue Box, which was kind of cyan, was built, my understanding is, largely by the Quickdraw team, which Quickdraw also had like a compatibility layer that they had built for Windows boxes. And so I've heard that, you know, the Cyan proposal had nothing to do with OSX and it was developed completely independently.
你知道的，据我们所知，你的直接下属或你向其汇报的人会说：好吧，你可以花一点时间，但我们还有别的事要做，所以，你知道的，别浪费两个星期去写这个破提案之类的。是的，太疯狂了。这是一个了不起的故事。而且我听过来自苹果内部相互矛盾的故事。被称为Blue Box的东西（也就是差不多Cyan），据我所知，很大程度上是由Quickdraw团队构建的，Quickdraw也为Windows系统构建了一个兼容层。所以我听说Cyan提案跟OS X毫无关系，它是完全独立开发的。
And then I've heard like, no, it had everything to do with it. And, you know, it wouldn't have been developed if it hadn't been for the Cyan proposal. You know, I think the truth is probably somewhere in the middle. I don't think it was a unique idea. And I think anybody who I had worked with at Apple, because we had been working on how do we support the evolution of the Mac onto new operating systems. Anybody who I had worked with who was still there would have come to the same conclusion. But I also think that having Adobe say no in less was a huge motivating factor. have where, you know, it's not uncommon for somebody's initial reaction to a thing to be, it can't be done, or this is a bad idea, or we shouldn't do this. And I think really the,
我也听过另一种说法：不，它跟OS X有着密不可分的联系，如果没有Cyan提案，它根本就不会被开发出来。你知道的，我认为真相可能介于两者之间。我不认为这是一个独一无二的想法。而且我认为任何我在苹果共事过的人——因为我们一直在研究如何支持Mac向新操作系统演进——任何留在那里的我曾共事过的人都会得出相同的结论。但我也认为，让Adobe拒绝在某种程度上是一个巨大的激励因素。你知道的，人们对某事的第一反应往往是“这做不到”或者“这是个坏主意”或“我们不该这么做”，这并不罕见。而我认为真正重要的是，
the, the key thing is not an initial reaction. The key thing, like when presented with a new idea that maybe challenges your, your perceptions, the key thing is when you go and think about it and you realize, Hey, maybe, maybe, maybe this was actually right. Maybe my gut reaction was just me being defensive. What do you do next? Because you can either double down or you can say, oh yeah, you know what? I'm going to change my position. And one of the things I've noticed about people that I consider very intelligent and who it seems being very successful is they are, when they recognize that they were wrong, they have no shame and no remorse about switching their position to what they now believe to be the reality of the world. And so like, you know, obviously Apple, Apple doesn't come off well in that engagement, but at least they eventually recognized that they needed to do the thing.
关键不在于第一反应。关键在于，当面对一个可能挑战你固有观念的新想法时，关键在于当你去思考它并意识到：嘿，也许……也许这个其实是对的呢？也许我的直觉反应只是出于自我防卫。你接下来会怎么做？因为你可以选择加倍固执，或者你可以说：哦，对了，你知道吗？我要改变我的立场。我注意到那些被我认为非常聪明且非常成功的人身上有一个特点，那就是当他们意识到自己错了时，他们会毫不羞耻、毫不内疚地将自己的立场转变为他们现在认为是世界真相的东西。所以，你知道的，显然苹果在那种互动中表现得并不好，但至少他们最终认识到他们需要去做那件事。
Yes. And yeah. And, you know, I think that that's very true. I'm notorious in meetings for arguing all sides of a problem. You know, I will argue against myself in a meeting and people are like, wait, you just said this other thing. And I'm like, well, now I'm taking the other position, right? So let's figure this out. And I'll frequently tell people when they say, you know, you can't do that. I'm like, do you know I can't do that? You know, do you know that that can't be done? Or do you just not know how to do it?
是的。而且，你知道的，我觉得这非常真实。我在会议上是出了名的喜欢就一个问题的各个方面展开争论。你知道的，我会在会议上反驳我自己，大家就会说：等等，你刚才可不是这么说的。而我会说：好吧，现在我站在另一个立场上了，对吧？所以让我们把这个问题弄清楚。每当有人说“你做不到那个”时，我经常会告诉他们：你怎么知道我做不到？你知道那根本做不到吗？还是说你只是不知道该怎么做？
Those are two different things. And, you know, if you know that can't be done, put together the rational argument, right? Connect the dots and basically, you know, prove it, prove that can't be done. So I think, uh, yes, yes. People are, are, are, are, are too dismissive. And a lot of times in my career, you know, if I've had a significant impact just because I've been like, no, you know, I can see that this is doable, and it's not a huge amount of work, and it can be scoped,
这是两码事。而且，如果你知道那是绝对做不到的，那就拿出合理的论据来，对吧？把这些点串联起来，基本上（你知道的）证明它，证明那确实做不到。所以我觉得，是的，人们……人们总是过于轻率地否定。在我的职业生涯中，很多时候，我之所以能产生显著的影响，仅仅是因为我说过：不，我能看出这件事是可行的，而且工作量并不大，它是可以划定范围的，
and there's a path that can get us from A to B, and it just comes out of sitting down and trying to look at, you know, okay, you know, people say it would be great if we could do blank, but everybody says we can't do blank. And I'm like, do we? Does, you know, is that really we can't do blank? Or is that just a bunch of people saying we don't know how to do blank? And so let's go go actually dig in and take a look at that problem. My, my youngest of three sisters, Piper, she works in finance. And she has this quote, I think it's a Ray Dalio. But it could be from some other famous hedge fund person that says, like genius or brilliance is the ability to
并且有一条路径可以把我们从A点带到B点，这仅仅源于坐下来尝试审视……好吧，人们说如果我们能做到某事就好了，但每个人都说我们做不到。而我在想：真的是这样吗？真的是我们做不到吗？还是只是一群人说“我们不知道该怎么作”？所以让我们去真正深入挖掘并研究一下这个问题。我三个姐姐里最小的妹妹派珀，她在金融界工作。她有一句名言，我觉得是雷·达里奥说的，但也可能是出自其他某个著名的对冲基金大佬之口，大意是：天才或才华，就是能够在头脑中
hold like multiple points of view in your head at the same time and like compare and contrast them. Because a lot of times in meetings, you see, you know, people go head to head. But like, real brilliance is like the ability to, you know, do what you were doing is, you know, take one side of an argument and then take the other side of the argument. Because at the end of the day, you shouldn't just be stuck to a decision, because that's the one that you chose, you should be looking at all angles, which is it's a hard thing to do. Yeah, I think it's important also to kind of seek out people who view the world differently than you do in tech. An individual who at Adobe, Mark Hamburg, he was lead on Photoshop when I joined the Photoshop team and then he and I worked later on a product called Revel. So we've
同时持有多种不同的观点，并将它们进行对比和权衡的能力。因为很多时候在会议上，你会看到人们针尖对麦芒。但真正的才华在于……就像你刚才做的那样，采纳一个论点的正方，然后采纳它的反方。因为归根结底，你不应该仅仅因为那是你选择的决定而固执己见，你应该审视所有的角度。这其实是一件很难做到的事。是的，我认为在科技界，去寻找那些看待世界的角度与你不同的人也很重要。在Adobe有个叫马克·汉堡的人，当我加入Photoshop团队时他是该团队的负责人，后来我和他一起开发过一个叫Revel的产品断断续续合作了，天哪，快接近30年了。
worked together off and on for, gosh, it's getting close to 30 years now. He's an absolutely brilliant individual, but he always manages to come at a problem from the opposite direction that I come at it from, you whatever the two of us are proposing as solutions, you would think that one of the two has to be wrong. And I have a huge amount of respect for Mark, technically, and his brain just works very differently than mine does. He solves problems in a very different way than i solve problems and what i usually find is is we're notorious for having these long drawn out very vocal arguments but yeah we're good friends we'll go out and get a beer afterwards the when we have these arguments it's like we both end up learning something right right and and usually we end up on a better solution than if either of us were trying to tackle the same problem alone and so he's somebody whose input i will i will seek out even though for whatever it is when i'm like oh i'm thinking about doing this and here's
他绝对是个天才，但他总是能从与我完全相反的方向来处理问题。无论我们俩提出什么解决方案，你都会觉得其中一个肯定是错的。在技术上我对马克抱有极大的敬意，他的大脑运作方式跟我的完全不同。他解决问题的方式跟我解决问题的方式大相径庭。我通常发现的是，我们出了名的喜欢进行这种旷日持久、激烈异常的争论。但没关系，我们是好朋友，事后我们会一起出去喝一杯。当我们进行这些争论时，感觉我们俩最终都能学到点什么，对吧？而且通常情况下，我们最终得出的解决方案，会比我们俩中任何一个人单枪匹马解决同一个问题要好得多。所以他是我会刻意寻求意见的人，尽管无论面对什么事，当我说“我考虑做这个，我是这么打算的”时，他最初的反应往往会是：
how i do it his initial response is going to be it's going to be you're wrong that's like a stupid way to do it right right right and i just know and expect that and it's like okay so so but he's going to propose something that's completely different which at first glance i will say well that looks ridiculous um but if i take the time to understand what he's saying it's like no that's not ridiculous there's some some amount of brilliance in there and if i if i understand where he's coming from i'll end up in a better place and so so i think in tech we tend to people tend to grav gravitate towards people who affirm their own you know their own belief systems and they form these little clusters and they kind of push out outside influences. And it's like, no, you want, you, you know, it's like you don't want to be the smartest person in the room
你错了，这简直是个愚蠢的做法。对吧，对吧，对吧。我早就知道并对此有所预期，心想：好吧。但他会提出一个完全不同的方案，乍一看我会觉得“这看起来太荒谬了”。但如果我花时间去理解他在说什么，就会发现：不，这并不荒谬，里面包含着某种天才的想法。如果我能理解他的出发点，我最终就会达到一个更好的结果。所以我觉得在科技界，人们往往倾向于聚拢那些能够肯定他们自身信仰体系的人，他们结成一个个小圈子，把外部的影响排挤在外。而事实上——不，你才不想成为房间里最聪明的人，
and you don't want to work in an environment that's homogenous, you know, that everybody's viewing things the same way. And that's why we should all learn APL. Perfect way to close it out. Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也不想在一个同质化的环境中工作，在那里所有人都用同一种方式看待问题。这就是为什么我们都应该学习APL。这是结束访谈的绝佳方式。是的，太棒了。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。